Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Na, was du gestern Nacht auch im Zoo.
Nee, ich war auf so einer kleinen, lauschigen Privatparty mit sechshunderttausend Leuten.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer dreihundertachtundachtzig vom achten April zweitausendeinundzwanzig.
Ja, ich weiß sogar, ich weiß sogar, wo die Party war, wo du warst.
Ja.
Zentrum. Da sind wir gestern sechshunderttausend irgendwie paar zerquetschte, geimpft worden.
Echt? Haben die das gestern so gut hingekriegt?
Ja, ich meine, wir haben jetzt irgendwie auch mal vier Millionen geliefert bekommen, da sollte er vielleicht auch mal irgendwas davon in irgendwelchen Armen landen.
Ja, es, es, ich kann tatsächlich Fortschritt bei der Impfung äh verzeichnen. Heute ist der Tag, an dem meine Eltern gefunden. Wichtiger, schöner Tag für mich, hat mich sehr gefreut, ja.
Haben sich heute Morgen ja, die haben sich das heute äh abgeholt und gut ist jetzt. Ist das schön? Ja, ne?
Was gab's feines?
AZ
AZ, sehr schön, das gute AZ.
Den den Rambo in Stoff, den den den Underdog Impfstoff nicht hier so eine schnösel Pampe da brauchen wir alles nicht. No risk go fun.
Der Underground Impfstoff. Sehr schön.
Also ein hin und her, ich meine, die die Regeln zum äh zu zu Astras äh äh
ändert sich ja öfter als die als wie viel mit wie vielen Leuten man noch in verschlossenen Raumen, im Kindergarten, äh unter Anwesenheit von Büro
Produktionsanlagen, wie viel Bier trinken kann. Also das ist ja äh ist ja ein ein Hin und Her.
Ist es, es ist was soll man machen mit der Realität leben wir jetzt und ähm es macht auch nicht so den Eindruck, als ob viele Leute da wären, die an diesem ganzen Verwirrspiel noch viel ändern würden.
Lass uns nicht über Politik reden, lass uns lieber über über schicke Apps reden. Smarte, lustige Apps und Fashion Startups machen wir heute hier.
Genau und über Tiere im Zoo, ja.
Tiere und und ja, was Spannendes, was zum Hecken. Und und Tiere.
Das ist unser Angebot für euch heute.
Die ganze Familie.
Ganze Familie. Ein Logbuch für die ganze Familie.
Ja, kommen wir äh zum Feedback. Kleiner Hinweis zu Beginn dieser Sendung, wer diese Sendung äh hört und die Davorsendung, die Sinn oder vor die drei, acht, sieben mit ähm,
Eva Wolfgang nicht gehört hat, sollte die zuerst hören ähm weil wir da sehr viel heute dran anschließen möchten.
Wir beginnen mit dem Feedback und zwar habe ich sehr viel.
Mich auf Restaurants bezogen in der letzten Sendung, bei der wir ja sehr viel über die Luca-App gesprochen haben. Und dazu gab es äh verschiedene Kommentare,
ähm jetzt habe ich die Namen nicht mit aufgeschrieben. Sekunde, äh zum Beispiel, genau, erster Kommentar von Beate, dir gesagt, ein Hinweis, ihr nennt als Beispiel immer Restaurants, die ja eh derzeit geschlossen sind.
Und die Luca-App daher dort nicht zum Einsatz kommt. Karlsruhe hat sich aber leider bereits entschieden, öffentliche Gebäude und Einrichtungen, die derzeit durchaus geöffnet sind mit Luca kurz zu versehen und dem Aufruf sich dort mit der App einzuchecken.
Ähnliche Berichte bekommen wir aus der Stadtbibliothek Freiburg und von einem Baumarkt in Berlin und noch von vielen anderen.
Das heißt ja, wir haben jetzt äh offenbar noch sehr viel mehr ähm Örtlichkeiten damit äh versehen und ähm,
ja, wichtiger Hinweis hier von Beate und einigen anderen.
Dann habe ich einen weiteren Fehler gemacht, der ist peinlich, da habe ich einen peinlichen Fehler gemacht. Der ist mir auch wirklich persönlich peinlich, auch wenn äh die wenigen, die mich darauf hingewiesen haben, äh sehr nachsichtig waren mit dem mit dem Fehler.
Und zwar kommentierte ähm,
als allererstes per, per Twitter DM von Ben bekommen, jemand der sich auch sehr viel mit dem
Äh Luca auseinandersetzt und da viel äh zitiert wird und viel herausfindet, äh in diesem, in diesem Kontext und ähm,
Moment, man, ich hätte es, sorry, das hätte ich hier besser machen müssen mit den.
Den Kommentaren verlinken. Äh dann kommentierte Fritzi,
Danke wie immer für den Podcast. Ich glaube aber, es hat sich ein kleiner Fehler eingeschlichen. Die fragliche JAT5 steht unter der
BSD-Lizenz. Damit entfällt auch der GPL-Teil der nachfolgenden Argumentation,
Eine Lizenzverletzung ist es natürlich trotzdem. Absolut richtig. Habe ich total falsch gesagt. Ich habe gesagt, es es stünde unter GPL und äh das Besondere an der GPL ist ja diese Infektion.
Und genau das hat aber die BSD nicht. Ja, die BSD ist die Burkly Systems äh oder wofür stehe ich?
So für das Revolution. Sofern.
Ah, wirklich. Eine Lizenz, die eine kommerzielle Nutzung erlaubt,
Ähm großer Unterschied zwischen den beiden Unique-Derivaten, die ja bekannt sind, also die gibt's diese BSD Schiene der Unixe und die,
Schiene der Unique City, die eben GnoLinux hauptsächlich ist. Ähm bei der BSD-Lizenz ist eine,
kommerzielle Verwendung auch unter ähm Veränderungen genehmigt,
und entsprechend ist ein BSD auch die Basis, die entfernte Basis von macOS, also macOS ist ein äh probletäres, nichtöffentliches BSD-Derivat, das hätte man mit einem Lynux,
nicht tun können? Habe ich das äh richtig zusammengefasst.
Das hast du äh richtig zusammengefasst, man könnte es auch noch mal ein bisschen einfacher äh machen. Im Prinzip steht die BSD und die GPL äh Familien, von Lizenzen für zwei unterschiedliche Vorstellungen von Freiheit,
die GPL-Lizenz eine quasi das Copyright auch missbraucht. Ja, also aktiv missbraucht
das heißt ja dann auch Copyleft, um quasi andere zu zwingen
jegliche auf diesem Code, auf dem jeweiligen mit GPL lizensierten Code äh aufbauende Arbeit
auch wiederum frei werden zu lassen. Das war diese Infektion, von der wir gesprochen haben. Ja, um sozusagen Freiheit zu erzwingen und zu verhindern, dass Code verschwindet in der Annahme, dass das dann passieren würde, während die BSD-Lizenz seine andere Mentalität ver,
und sagt so, wir sind frei, es in mach doch, was du willst. Einzige Ausnahme, du musst schon sagen,
dass du den Code verwendet hast, du musst schon hinschreiben, von wem das ursprünglich war, wenn du die Copyrights Meldung nicht noch mitführst und mit veröffentlicht, dann hast du gegen diese Lizenz auch verstoßen. Und das ist das, was jetzt in diesem Fall passiert ist.
Hast du einen, also es ist dann es ist dann nichts anderes als ein Plagiat,
Du hast sie immer, du hast das gestohlen, hast du gegen die Lizenzbedingungen verstoßen, hast da irgendeine äh Library drin mit einer Funktionalität, die du ja sogar verkaufst für nicht ganz so Schmalenthaler? Spulen wir gleich auch nochmal drüber.
Man könnte sagen, die Luca-App steht unter der Gutenberg Public Leistens.
Ja genau,
Gutenberg Public, sehr schön, sehr schön. Ähm anonym hat das auch, hat richtig vermutet, warum ich den Fehler gemacht habe.
Ja, das ist mir auch aufgefallen, ich vermute, dass Linus angenommen hat, dass die Wahl der neuen Lizenz für die Android-App,
auf GPL drei gefallen ist, weil er fälschlicherweise annahm, dass JBC auch GPL, V3 ist
Das wäre dann logisch und notwendig, ja, also,
das ist genau das, was ich vermutet habe, aber wie gesagt, das war falsch. Ist nicht der Fall. Spannend, jetzt weiter der Kommentar. Spannend ist daher das, was der eigentliche Grund,
die Wahl der GPL V3, für die Android-App,
wahr, also warum haben die denn dann die GPL genommen? Es hätte ja auch sein können, auch eine äh freie Lizenz, was bei vielen der eingesetzten Librarys der Fall ist.
Vermutung ist, sagt anonym, dass sie damit wollen, dass mögliche Forks auch unter GPL bleiben müssen, wie von Linus erklärt wurde. Das ergibt aber auch.
Dass sie bei jedem Release der Luca-App den Code veröffentlichen müssen, um nicht gegen die GPL zu verstoßen. Oder sie fahren Dual Leißens, ein öffentliches Repo als GPL und ein internes Pro-Prietäres.
Inwieweit kann man dann vertrauen, dass die veröffentlichen Apps auch dem Code aus dem öffentlichen entsprechen.
Das ist immer so ein große, das ist immer so ein Thema und ganz ehrlich, ich finde das, es ist auch aus einer technischen Perspektive wichtig, ja, ist eine Frage, die gestellt werden muss, aber,
ähm insgesamt kann man eigentlich schon davon ausgehen, dass die Luca-App ungefähr dem dem Stand entspricht, weil man sieht ja die ganzen Fehler
sowohl im Quellcode als auch in der funktionierenden App und ähm es gibt da jetzt wenig ähm Vermutung, dass man da noch irgendwelche geheimen Hintertüftfunktionen hat, weil das Ding ja sowieso
äh also weil da ja eh alles falsch gemacht ist, äh was man falsch machen kann, auch dazu kommen wir später nochmal.
Antibiotika habe ich erwähnt.
Oh ja. Ich habe in dem Moment noch dran gedacht, aber hab's irgendwie.
Wollte, es war ja, es ich wollte es ja nur als kleines Beispiel nehmen, dass man eben nicht übertherapiert mit dem äh Holzhammer oder mit dem Vorschlaghammer und habe gesagt, Erkältungen werden nicht mit Antibiotika therapiert,
erklärt AD oder AD. Ich weiß immer noch nicht, könntest du das nächste Mal erklären, wenn du kommentierst. Also
Erkältungen werden ganz überwiegend von Viren ausgelöst, unter anderem von Coronaviren. Wer weiß, vielleicht zukünftig auch von SARS-KoV zwei. Penicillin,
Penicilliné sind aber eine Gruppe
von Antibiotika. Sie helfen also bei bakteriellen Infektionen. Es gibt auch mal Konstellationen, wo eine Erkältung zusätzlich mit einer solchen Infektion einhergeht, aber im Allgemeinen müsste man, wenn schon.
Mit einem Therapeutikum gegen den viralen Erreger vorgehen und da hilft Penicilin überhaupt nicht. Im Gegenteil ist die Verschreibung von Antibiotika auch in Fällen, wo sie nicht helfen, einer der Treiber der nächsten potenziellen Krankheitskrise
Man hat zunehmend Probleme mit antibiotikaresistenten Bakterien und,
Es ist nicht undenkbar, dass uns sogar die Reserveantibiotika ausgehen können. Ab da würde ich dann auch von Knieoperationen abraten. Stimmt?
Jeder Antibiotikaeinsatz ähm züchtet,
oder ihr übt evolutionären Druck auf, die Bakterien und Keime aus Resistenz gegen diese ähm,
Antibiotika aufzubauen, das heißt du züchtest mit der Maßnahme ganz, ganz langsam äh Bakterienstämme, an die äh dem,
Antibiotikum gewachsen sind. Ich glaube, die bekanntesten sind die äh MRSA,
resistenten Staphylokoken
Auri oder Aureose, weiß nicht genau, wie man's auf Deutsch sagt. Äh das ist ein großes Problem in den Krankenhäusern. Nennt man auch die Krankenhauskeime, dass die Stör machen nichts besonders schlimmes,
stören einfach nur die Wundheilung und die wirst du im Leben nicht mehr los und bist dann eben ein äh Infektionspatient und das ist ein,
Das ist quasi so der der leichte Vorgeschmack auf ähm.
Noch nicht ganz so besonders üble, aber schon sehr scheiße störende Keime, ähm die eben im, bei Krankenhausaufenthalten, in Wunden und so echt eine,
eine fiese Nummer sind, die willst du nicht haben und äh das sind jetzt ja wie gesagt, die machen noch nichts Schlimmes. Aber wenn du dann demnächst mal,
anderen Bakterien hast, die äh multiresistent sind gegen unterschiedliche Antibiotika, dann wird das nochmal witzig. Und deswegen
ist, glaube ich, wenn ich das richtig sage, ansonsten korrigiert mich in der nächsten Sendung ähm ist das ja auch so gefährlich, dass den Tieren,
ganze Zeit Antibiotika gegeben werden, obwohl sie die nicht brauchen. Das ist ja in der Massentierhaltung das große Problem und diese Antibiotika, die nehmen wir dann auch äh teilweise über die Nahrung zu uns und da züchten wir in diesen.
In diesen Massentierhaltungsbereichen, wo wir Tiere unter Bedingungen halten, unter denen die überhaupt nicht,
äh überlebensfähig werden und und hygienischen Bedingungen, mit denen die überhaupt nicht klar kommen könnten und das einfach durch Antibiotika möglich machen. Da züchten wir uns auch die ganze Zeit,
Bakterienstämme an.
Ja, das ist vor allem in der Schweineproduktion ein großes Problem. Dadurch, dass die ganzen Zucht äh Bedingungen in Deutschland der Gestalt,
geregelt sind, dass da eben die Schweine sehr eng auf eng äh leben müssen und relativ äh wenig dafür getan wird, auch so gut stellen und Haltungsstellen irgendwie auseinander zeiten. Ich bin jetzt auch nicht weiter vertiefen,
da wird dann halt äh viel zu früh mit ähm antibakteriellen Medikamenten gegengehalten und oft halt auch schon aus dieser Reserve,
gearbeitet, was halt eigentlich für dich nur für Notfälle vorgesehen ist und wenn man das macht, dann ist halt die Reserve irgendwann der Normalfall und dann hat man auch keine Reserve mehr. Na ja, auf jeden Fall ähm.
Eigentlich wolltest du sagen, Viren.
Ja, eigentlich wollte ich Viren sagen und äh ich äh weiß es tatsächlich, ich hab's nur falsch gesagt. Oder ich hätte, ich hätte es gewusst.
So ist das nämlich immer bei uns, wenn wir was falsches sagen. Wir wissen es eigentlich.
In dem Fall tatsächlich, weiß ich's tatsächlich, weil ich das äh gelernt habe.
Hast du aufgepasst.
Verschiedenen eben. Ne, ich war ja Rettungssanitäter früher und äh habe da auch äh Infektionsfahrten gemacht mit MSA-Patienten und solche Sachen. Ähm.
QR-Codes kommentierte Jannik super Folge. Folgendes ist euch sicherlich auch schon bei Luca aufgefallen. Aus den QR-Codes der Locations lassen sich super einfach die Kamerascannerseiten aufrufen, die das Einchecken der Nutzerinnen
mit ihren QR-Codes, Handys oder Schlüsselanhänger ermöglichen. Jetzt müssen wir eigentlich nur noch auf den Moment warten, an dem.
Mögliche Politikerinnen stolz bei der Einführung von Luca in ihrem Heimatort ihre Handys oder Schlüsselanhänger in die Kameras halten. Ab hier lassen sich dann Locations und Nutzerinnen.
Auf kreative Weise kombinieren. Das wird ein Spaß. Äh es dauerte nicht lange, bis darauf geantwortet wurde, ja Jannik, genau das ist jetzt auch gerade passiert,
denn,
äh begann, wenn ich das jetzt richtig erinnere damit, dass jemand einen großen Aufsteller des Zoos Osnabrück fotografierte. Ähm und sagte hier, ne,
Luca App. So und,
diesen QR-Code konnten natürlich jetzt alle nutzen, die auch nicht im Zoo Osnabrück waren, um diesen Zoo Osnabrück, äh um sich dort einzuchecken.
Gleichzeitig gab es diese Schwachstelle, in dem Erstellen von Schlüsselanhängern, so dass im Prinzip alles irgendwie mit Mülldaten, Skriptbar war. Ähm.
Ja, Jan Bümmer, man twitterte, dass ihr irgendwie und sagte, ey, geile App, ich war gerade noch hier, jetzt bin ich im heute Nacht bin ich im Zoo Osnabrück und dann halt noch äh jemand Weiteres
so ein Skript gezählt, was quasi die Besucherzahl ist, die nächtlichen Besucherzahlen des Zoo Osnabrück äh zeigte und äh es gab da eine kleine
Corona-Party im Zoo Osnabrück. War jetzt erstmal ganz lustig und.
Jetzt muss man dazu sagen, das ist eine allgemeine äh Schwäche von QR-Codes, dass das so ist und das hat im Zweifelsfall jedes,
QR-Code basierte System, ne, dass sich diese QR Codes eben sehr leicht,
mit der Kamera ähm auf andere in andere begeben, in andere äh Umgebungen
bewegen lassen. Und natürlich haben sie alle die waren ja alle stolz auf ihren Luca. Findest du im Internet und auf Facebook alle möglichen Leute, die sagen, ne, hier bei uns im,
im Supermarkt, äh was ist das hier? Ihr könnt da mit dem Luca scannen und äh entsprechend war die,
Freude dann groß, dann gab's ja echt noch irgendwie und da bin ich mir auch irgendwie nicht ganz sicher, was irgendwie mit dem los ist. Hat da noch,
der Datenschutzbeauftragte von, ist das Baden-Württemberg Stefan Brink, irgendwo da die Ecke, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, welches ähm Bundesland ich glaube, Baden-Württemberg war das, aber kann sein, dass ich mich täusche
der rügte dann auch noch den den Böhmermann dafür, dass er das gemacht hat. Was mir jetzt auch nicht ganz klar war, was das sollte und.
Jetzt gab es da auch noch den Punkt, dass wenn du mit so einem Schlüsselanhänger eincheckst.
Musst du quasi durch Präsentation des Schlüsselanhängers auch wieder auschecken. Und in dem Backend können die Leute nur entweder alle Schlüsselanhänger auschecken.
Aber kein spezifischen und da sieht man dann schön das hat die vielen von euch sicherlich bekannt von der LNP dreihundert wahrscheinlich ne?
Wo die äh Anke bei uns war oder weil das zweihundertsechsundfünfzig, ich weiß es nicht, eine von beiden. Ähm,
zeigte dann auch diesen diesen Screenshot, dass nämlich der Zoo Osnabrück dann offenbar irgendwann am nächsten Morgen gegen acht Uhr die Corona-Party mit hundert Leuten oder auch hundertzwanzig Leuten da aufgelöst hat und alle ausgecheckt hat. So.
Weiter ging es damit, dass Enno Lenze ein privates Event angelegt hat,
Also man kann in der Luca-App eine, ne, eine Location schaffen und das wäre dann der Zoo Osnabrück. Achso, da würde ich noch ganz kurz anmerken.
Wie blöd sind die Schimpansen vom Zoo Osnabrück, dass die sich da so einen Luca Code vorhängen? So.
Zoo hat irgendwie zwanzig Hektar oder so und ist eine Frei ist ein Freiluftgehege für Menschen. So und.
Da einen Luka QR-Code zu machen. Da fragst du dich doch wirklich, ähm.
Ob die Schimpansen beim äh beim äh Medizinstudium aufgepasst haben. Also dass das keine sinnvolle Einheit für eine äh für eine Contact-Tracing Erfassung ist, sollte ja allen klar sein.
Oder setze ich da jetzt einen zu hohen Maßstab der privaten Forschung an.
Also die Frage ist ja ohnehin, was was will man überhaupt mit diesem Code an dieser Stelle bewirken? Ja, Sinn der ganzen Sache ist ja, wenn man sozusagen äh.
Man soll ja eine Liste führen für das Gesundheitsamt. Musste der Zoo vorher auch schon diese Liste führen?
Hat sich jeder im Zoo in so eine Liste eingetragen und gesagt, ich bin jetzt im Zoo.
Aber nur eine halbe Stunde. Also.
Ja, also das war doch nicht war doch nie der Fall.
Ja die der stand auch auf diesem Aussteller stand für zusätzliche Sicherheit. Da frage ich mich auch.
Ja
Quantifiziert die bitte. Gebt mir bitte eine äh also wie viel zusätzliche Sicherheit kriege ich?
Wenn ich im Zoo Osnabrück bin zumal, wenn ich gar nicht da bin.
Also qualifizieren wir sind ja, ich würde gerne mal erklären, welcherlei Sicherheit dadurch jetzt eigentlich wem wodurch hinzuge,
wird. Also es ist mir jetzt gerade nicht so ganz klar, was was das jetzt für ein Sicherheitsgewinn ist. Sicherheit, wovor eigentlich, vor was? Vor den Affen oder oder.
Also wirklich ein, also da merkst du auch wie wie schmerzhaft das ist.
Sind die Leute dann beim Arzt, kriegen ihr einen positiven Test und dann sagen die, ja wieso, aber ich habe doch den QR-Code gescannt. Kann auch gar nicht sein.
Der Schimpanse konnte mich doch gar nicht anstecken. Ja, also total, äh also wirklich absoluter Unsinn, absoluter Unsinn. Und ähm.
Hier eben
entspanntet. Die Luca-App-Leute sind ja wirklich nicht besonders gute äh nicht besonders gut in der in der öffentlichen Kommunikation, müssen aber offenbar besonders gut in der Kommunikation hinter verschlossenen Türen sein. Aber da kommen wir gleich nochmal zu. Also, Enno Lenze geht hin und sagt.
Ich mache jetzt mal äh ein privates Event auf. Möchtet ihr,
meinem privaten Event dabei sein. Und twittert den QR-Code, den die Luca-App quasi dann erstellt, ne, also du warst die Luca-App auf und sagst, ich mache jetzt hier ein privates Event,
und dann.
Hat er den Screenshot getwittert und die Leute haben dann mit ihm ein privates Event gemacht. Es hat nicht lange gedauert, weil du quasi auch IDs,
faken kannst äh und schnell anlegen kannst, bis dieses Event dann irgendwo in nördlich der sechshunderttausend Leute.
Besucht hatten, weil irgendjemand halt einfach ein Skript geschrieben hat, was die ganze Zeit diesem Event beitritt. Ja?
Und äh alle lachten freulich und haben dann da irgendwie, nen Zeit regelmäßig so jetzt sind wir schon vierhunderttausend. So und dann.
War dieses Event auf einmal weg. Dann hatte quasi von Luca Seite wurde dieses Event.
Gelöscht, weil ja ein offensichtlicher Missbrauch der App stattgefunden hätte. Und.
Da bin ich ja hellhörig geworden, weil das heißt, A dieses private Event wird ebenfalls auf deren Server getrackt.
Und dieses private Event haben sie nicht nur getrackt, sondern auch eingegriffen und das gelöscht, weil es ihnen nicht gefallen hat. Und das ist genau der Grund, ja, warum du,
eine zentrale Erfassung haben willst, weil sie dir irgendwie sagt, ja ist doch voll geil, mach doch mal ein privates Event, kannst du auch auf unseren Servern tracken,
Und wir wissen dann, welche Nutzer wie zusammengehangen haben?
Und äh wenn uns dann irgendwie nicht gefällt, was du machst, dann löschen wir das. Ja? Hätte, würdest du so etwas mit machen? Ja? Gäbe es noch nicht einmal,
eine Möglichkeit, irgendwo zu zählen, wie viele Leute bei dem Event waren. Niemand wüsste,
ähm das ist dieses Event überhaupt gäbe, insbesondere nicht die App äh Crowd-Notifyer oder Notify Me. Ähm und sie könnten auch nichts dagegen tun, dass es das gibt,
Und genau das ist ja der korrekte.
Der korrekte Ansatz, ja? Und dass du da jetzt irgendwie äh dass dann irgendwelche Luca-Leute sagen, wir löschen das jetzt, muss gewissermaßen sagen, das haben, glaube ich, auch nicht alle verstanden, was das bedeutet hat, dass die dieses Event gelöscht haben, dass sie es nämlich konnten
Ähm aber du fragst dich ernsthaft wie wie die drauf sind, dass die das ernsthaft für eine adäquate Lösung halten?
Ja, weil was ist mit den drei Leuten, die jetzt tatsächlich bei Enno Lenze im Wohnzimmer saßen?
Ja, die sind jetzt gearscht. Und ähm insbesondere war offenbar, dass äh habe ich aber jetzt nur gelesen.
Ich konnte gar nicht mehr dem Event beitreten, weil da hatten sie's schon gelöscht. Ähm offenbar.
Äh war es dann so, bei denen, die dem Event beigetreten waren oder oder war es nur bei NONO so? Die die App ist dann immer abgestürzt, weil dieses Event weg war,
und er musste dann quasi Luca neu installieren und hat dadurch seine Location, seine seine bisherigen Check-Ins verloren.
Wieder mal, ne? Nicht,
zu Ende gedacht. Aber äh ja, in meinen Augen die entscheidende, die entscheidende Lehre daraus ist, die wissen nicht nur in Echtzeit von den von allen privaten Treffen und wie viele Leute da sind, sondern die können auch,
aktiv darin eingreifen, das ist genau der Grund, warum man eben kein zentrales System haben möchte.
Um's gleich mal klar zu machen, die eigentliche Bedrohung, also ich meine,
Klar war das offensichtlich, dass das jetzt hier äh an sich eine Fake-Geschichte war, ne? Man könnte ja auch schnell äh jetzt so äh drauf reagieren und sagen so, ja wieso, aber das war ja eh nichts. Es schatt ja nix, wenn es wegmacht.
Problem ist halt einfach, Zugriff ist möglich und damit weißt du halt schon überhaupt nicht, was mit diesem Datenbestand äh passiert.
Das birgt natürlich immer wieder auch die Möglichkeit, einfach für für Fehler.
Also ähm das übersetzt auf ähm,
äh äh Corona-Warn-App äh Anpassung, die kommen wird. Das mit den QR-Codes wird da auch funktionieren, ja? Ähm und,
Wie es sich gehört, werden die aber nicht werden die nicht zentral getrackt und ja, das also das geht, ne? Das geht bei jedem manuellen Check-In System und gewissermaßen kann man auch argumentieren
dass das gut und sinnvoll ist, weil außer ein paar Spaßvögel, die mal gucken wollen, was passiert.
Ist es nicht wahrscheinlich, dass ähm dass es jetzt absichtlich von vielen die ganze Zeit gemacht wird, aber es wäre beispielsweise auch ein äh potenzieller Angriff, ja,
Dass du dir einen Luca äh QR-Code machst, einen Eigen, einen einzigen.
Und druckst dir Aufkleber mit dem Luca-Logo und klebst den überall hin. Tapezierst damit die Berliner U-Bahn,
ne? Mach's was weiß ich, machst du an der Weltzeituhr am Alexanderplatz. Checken Sie hier bitte mit Luca ein und sammelst damit äh ganz, ganz viele Check-Ins, die dann potenziell äh alarmiert würden.
Da kommt allerdings, muss man jetzt auch sagen, äh potenziell auch eine,
Stärke des Lukas-Systems zum Tragen, weil die könnten ja ähm quasi diese diese Notification dann unterbinden. Ja, würdest du das mit einem dezentralen System machen.
Dann äh wäre potentiell, wenn das System dir nicht als Nutzerin ermöglicht zu sagen, okay, diese Zusammenkunft alarmieren diese nicht,
was ich sehr hoffe, dass das in der Corona-Warn-App so sein wird, ja, aber Anhaltspunkte habe, dass es nicht so sein wird. Ähm.
Dann wäre das also potenziell ebenfalls ein möglicher Angriff quasi einfach überall Fake QR kurz hinzukleben und insbesondere da, wo wo keine hingehören und dann so eine Massengruppe zu machen,
zeigt aber auch einen anderen Aspekt, dass nämlich diese diese Daten.
In der Regel eben auch eine Interpretation bedürfen, ja? So, es ist eben einfach auch äh insbesondere Luca löst nicht das Problem der örtlichen Bedingungen,
ja. Da gibt's übrigens schöne Vorschläge,
von ich glaub das war wenn ich mich nicht täusche die sagten dieses Protokoll um quasi,
Sender, die die die Gegebenheiten wiedergeben,
Ja, also zum Beispiel, du befindest dich in einem Innenraum oder nicht in einem Innenraum, was eben eine für die Standard-Corona-Warn-App eine potenziell sehr interessante Information sein könnte, aber äh darum soll's jetzt hier nicht gehen.
Wir haben hier eine eine katastrophale,
Umsetzung, das kann man inzwischen einfach nicht mehr anders sagen, weil ach so, sorry, ich muss noch, noch 'ne Schwachstelle, Chaos, äh, Computerclub Freiburg haben festgestellt, wenn du dich da registrierst, da war ja ohnehin schon dieser Registrierungsprozess kaputt,
Das heißt, die Tannen, die sie dir dazu schicken, auf dein Handy, da kann dein Handy ja einfach behaupten, die bekommen zu haben.
Also du du verifizierst ja in Anführungszeichen deine Telefonnummer, indem sie dir eine eine TAN senden und dann kannst du aber auch einfach sagen, yo, ich habe die bekommen und die war richtig. Aber die Prüfung machen sie nicht mit dir
Deswegen ist dieses ganze SMS-Tannenverfahren ja sowieso schon Unsinn, ja, also du kannst darauf verzichten, du kannst auf beliebige Telefonnummern.
Luca registrieren, einfach indem du behauptest, du hättest die SMS schon bekommen, ja? Du musst es nicht beweisen.
War das nicht ein Fehler, der jetzt nur in Zusammenhang mit diesem Schlüsselanhänger äh passiert hat, mit diesen ausgedruckten QR-Codes.
Nee, das ich habe das so verstanden, dass der auch bei der normalen Registrierung über einen Webbrowser funktionierte.
Unabhängig davon, aber das war jetzt auch nur der der eine Punkt. Jetzt kommt äh der der Aspekt, dass dieses System eine SMS-Tann versendet.
Dieser diese dieses EP, dieser EPI-Endpunkt ist nicht irgendwie gesichert,
gesichert wäre, äh dass du zum Beispiel einen Capture davor machst. Oder,
irgendetwas das verhindert, dass sich jemand mit fünf Zeilen besh.
Telefonnummern würfelt und der SMS hinschicken lässt. Was sie natürlich dann gemacht haben, also der du kannst durch einen einfachen Request an diesen EPI-Endpunkt.
Eine äh ungewollte SMS-Nachrichten, eine beliebige Telefonnummern senden.
Ähm und die SMS ist dann irgendwie dein Luca äh Tarn lautet, ne? Und äh diese SMS wird dir natürlich auch was kosten, das wird aber eher im äh Bruchteile eines Cent-Bereich liegen.
Aber auch das haben sie nicht ordentlich gemacht und spannenderweise ist das auch in dem äh veröffentlichen Penetration Test.
Der ja Mitte März veröffentlicht wurde als Schwachstelle bereits gefunden. Der wurde im Dezember zwanzig zwanzig gemacht. Da wird also die Problematik geschildert und laut Bericht hätten sie die behoben. Das ist auch wieder so ein Klassiker.
Man macht den Pentest, man behebt die Schwachstellen, man lässt aber nicht von der kompetenten Stelle, die die Schwachstelle gefunden hat, nochmal prüfen, ob sie auch wirklich beseitigt wurde oder,
andere Möglichkeit, sie hatten die zwischenzeitlich beseitigt und dann haben sie wieder einen anderen Schimpansen aus dem Osnabrücker Zoo äh weiter programmieren lassen,
ähm und entsprechend äh den Fehler wieder eingebaut, der vorher schon mal weg war.
So, jetzt denkt man sich, ah, das kann ja mal passieren, ne? Man kann ja mal so ein Fehlerchen machen so und jetzt möchte ich nochmal auf die Preise hinweisen.
Baden-Württemberg, bezahlt für das erste Jahr, Luca.
Drei Komma sieben Millionen Euro fürs.
Und das ist eines von sechzehn Bundesländern und Baden-Württemberg ist bei weitem nicht das Größte Bundesland. Der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, nicht das kleinste, aber auch nicht das Größte,
und wenn man davon jetzt mal extra poliert und sich vorstellt, dass andere Bundesländer ähnliche Preise zahlen. Und auch drei Komma sieben Millionen,
in dieser Richtung zahlen. Wir hatten ja auch mit Eva bei der letzten Sendung darüber gesprochen. Ja, er hatte sie ja gesagt, sie weiß bisher von zehn Millionen,
Ja, aber bei einigen weiß man's nicht, was da an Kohle geflossen ist, aber wenn Deutschland aus sechzehn Baden-Württembergen bestünde.
Dann wären das schon sehr viel Geld.
Das wäre oh, ich darf gar nicht dran denken, ne. Wir können ja mal irgendwie auf die, ich weiß nicht, was für einen Faktor die da zu Grunde liegen, ob jetzt eventuell die die Einwohnerzahl nehmen oder oder was auch immer, aber drei Komma sieben Millionen für,
aufgebohrten, gestohlenen QR-Codescanner.
Ist ein guter Deal für unsere Lukas würde ich sagen.
Also wir können das ja mal hochrechnen, ja.
Wie viele Einwohnerinnen hat Baden-Württemberg?
Müll, elf Millionen.
Ah ja, okay.
Das heißt, du kannst es halt Gruppen mal acht nehmen. Ein bisschen weniger. So ähm ja und dann.
Irgendwo knapp unter dreißig. Für ein Jahr.
Für ein Jahr, das ist irgendwie die Hälfte von dem, was die Bundesrepublik in die Corona-Barn-App reingesteckt hat.
Gilt aber die ganze Zeit. Wobei da, da müsste ja, ich meine, da ist ja auch die meiste Kohle in die ähm.
Großer Teil ist vor allem in die Infrastruktur dieser äh Hotline geflog
und was weiß ich, was da noch in der äh Anbindung alles versenkt wurde an die ganzen Labore, aber das sind ja auch alles so
ähm nachvollziehbare äh Dinge, also ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie das ist mit der Auslassung, diese Hotline gelaufen ist und so weiter, das wird sicherlich irgendwann nochmal nachgerechnet werden, aber,
Erstmal nur von der App ausgeht und ein bisschen Anbindung im Backend, dann kannst du wahrscheinlich sogar sagen, vom Aufwand her äh ist das dann so die Hälfte von dem Ganzen.
Ja, aber du kannst halt auch irgendwie so ein, so eine, so eine Datenwurst da äh nehmen, die.
Konzeptionell einfach falsch aufgestellt ist,
einem danach auch nicht gehört. So, ich meine, die Corona-Warn-App gehört halt einfach der Bundesregierung und das das ist irgendwie äh ein solides Open-Source-Projekt. Das hat das hat einen Wert. Auf dem Code haben auch viele andere aufgebaut,
ne? Und ähm ja. Was haben wir dazu noch sagen?
Aber weißt du, was Tim? Das Geld ist weg. Weg! Das hast du jetzt gehabt!
Zuvor war's schöner, allein zu sein, wat ein Scheiß, ey. Es ist oh
Aber die haben sich echt gedacht, sind vielleicht könnten wir so eine geile Nummer machen, wie die Apotheken, ey. Und und gleichzeitig suchen sie irgendwelche unter Studenten irgendwelche Praktikanten. Ach so, das war übrigens auch noch eine Sache, die ich in der letzten Sendung vergessen hatte. Ich hatte da ja aus der
äh E-Mail zitiert, die der Professor, wie hieß er meine?
Verschickt hatte am HPI. Der ist Anteilseigner von.
Der ist äh mit den mit den beiden Gründern. Es ist ja ein eine wie wie man so schön nennt, eine Ausgründung und dieses Unternehmen, für das er da,
unter seinen Studierenden und Doktorandinnen wirbt. An diesem Unternehmen hat er Anteile. Das hat er in dieser E-Mail jetzt nicht unbedingt erwähnt,
ne? Das muss eben in dem Moment entfallen sein. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das äh äh irgendwie,
schlecht ist oder falsch, aber ist auf jeden Fall ungünstig gewesen, dass der gute,
Professor Meine, in dem Fall dann auch noch sein eigenes finanzielles Interesse ähm,
vergisst in in seiner Mail als Professor, äh wo er seinen wissenschaftlichen Mitarbeiterinnen, Studierenden und Doktorandinnen.
Die Arbeit beim HPI Startup Nexen empfiehlt. Ja, das ist äh,
Mann, ey, weißt du? Und dann ärgerst du dich, dass ähm.
Dass die Leute an irgendwelche Verschwörungstheorien glauben. Verschwörungstypen soll ich sagen, tut mir leid. Tja, so ist das,
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern.
Hat das jetzt schon sich eingetreten.
Hat es sich eingetreten und mir wurde hier gerade die Corona-Landesverordnung Mecklenburg äh Vorpommern,
zugeschickt, die jetzt nochmal am siebenundzwanzigsten März einem Update unterzogen wurde.
Und da gibt es, sind jetzt irgendwie die vier verschiedenen Anordner, Maßnahmen zur regionalen Lockerung und so weiter. Und wenn man dadrin nach Luca sucht, findet man immer wieder den Satz äh bla bla bla.
Äh die ich zitiere mal hier so ein Beispiel. Die Landkreise und freien Städte dürfen in der Allgemeinverfügung die Pflicht zur Dokumentation zur Kontaktnachverfolgung auf diese einen
erweitern. Soweit das unter Infektionsgeschehen dies erfordert. Dabei ist sicherzustellen, dass sie in den Anlagen genannten Anforderungen an die Datenverarbeitung zu Zweckbestimmung, Vertraulichkeit und Transparenz
gewährleistet sind. Die verpflichtende Dokumentation,
Kontaktnachverfolgung soll in elektronischer Form landeseinheitlich mittels Luca-App erfolgen.
Also die sagen jetzt im Prinzip, wir wollen äh wir verpflichten die äh dass die dass,
die Leute, dass äh Luca äh angewendet wird. Dann gibt's für bestimmte Auflagen, für Betriebe des Heilmittelbereiches und körpernahe Dienstleistung,
da wird gesagt, die verpflichtende Dokumentation zur Kontaktnachverfolgung soll in elektronischer Form landeseinheitlich mittels der Luca-App erfolgen. Hierbei entfällt die Verpflichtung eine Plausibilitäts,
Prüfung durchzuführen,
Ja, das bedeutet nämlich bei äh bei an, würde jemand einen anderen Weg wählen, äh liegt die Last der Polarosibilitätsprüfung bei den Leuten, ne, bei den äh Betreiberinnen der Einrichtung.
Und wenn sie äh die Luca-App nutzen, brauchen sie es nicht mehr machen
Ja? Und da gibt's dann irgendwie, das steht hier, dieser Satz steht hier sehr oft drin, was dann irgendwie Auflagen für Proben von Chören und muss Musik-Ensemble, das im Profibereich äh,
Büchereien, Bibliotheken, ne? Für die unterschiedlichen Stellen, da steht jedes Mal, ach so
Auflagen für Zoos, Tierparks, Vogelparks und botanische Gärten,
mit Außenbereich verpflichtende Dokumentation zur Kontaktnachverfolgung soll in elektronischer Form landeseinheitlich mittels der Luca-App erfolgen. Hierbei entfällt die Verpflichtung eine Plausibilitätsprüfung durchzuführen.
Wir auch, aber das heißt, ähm das heißt ja dann auch, nachdem jetzt alle so viel rumgezetert haben, ob denn die Corona-Warn-App Pflicht werden soll und vorgeschrieben wird.
Immer groß und so, ne, da denkt keiner dran. Würdest du jetzt einfach so gemacht mit einem mit einer App von irgendeinem Set Partyhersteller? Ihr seid jetzt alle äh gezwungen, diese App zu installieren,
Mit der dann wahrscheinlich ab nächstem Jahr irgendwie Tickets für Konzerte verkauft werden. Und das steht dann so im Gesetz drin.
Also das das geht einfach mal überhaupt nicht.
Das ist eine richtige, also das ist so eine richtig schöne Plünderung, die da gerade stattfindet.
Das ist einfach mal Start-up-Förderung in einer Dimension, wie wir sowieso bisher noch nicht gehabt haben.
Echt krass. Also und ich war also.
Wir haben ja in der letzten Sendung auch schon gesagt, so dass diese diese Namenerfassung ohnehin auf sehr zweifelhaftem Fundament steht. Ja, gibt.
Wenig Hinweise darauf, dass das besonders schnell laufen würde. Es gibt wenig Hinweise darauf, dass diese äh erfassten Daten tatsächlich von den Gesundheitsämtern auch angewendet werden.
Es ist eher so ein äh Wunschdenken.
Und da werden jetzt mal irgendwie in ihr wirklich in irgendwelche und ich kann es nur noch einmal betonen.
Windige Covid-Glücksritter, die da irgendeinen Shit zusammen programmieren und sich einen Prominenten nehmen, der durch alle Talkshows tingelt und du kannst ihr wirklich, also du staunst.
Wie deren ähm Werbung nachgeplappert wird,
Es ist also wirklich, war ja auch habe das ja auch gesagt, dass ich von diesem Tagesthemenbeitrag durchaus erschüttert war, was da los war, ne? Die haben kein fertiges Produkt und da wird gesagt, ey jetzt, jetzt Leute, kommt die Rettung, ja?
Und,
auch irgendwelche Artikel ja die dann so ey Hamburg geil Hamburg kann jetzt oh die fantastischen vier bekämpfen jetzt die die Pandemie und du fragst also,
Ich hatte irgendwo mal, ich habe irgendwann mal so geträumt, dass ich im Land leben würde, wo es so halbwegs seriöses Personal gibt, ne und wo wo es irgendwie eine kritische Presse gibt und eine eine Politik, die irgendwie rational,
versucht vorzugehen und ja sich irgendwie sinnvoll beraten lässt. Stattdessen musst du dir dann angucken äh wie die Professorin Brinkmann, die sich ja für eine für für ähm
sagen wir mal, die dafür, die für ähm Evidenzbasierte und wirksame Maßnahmen zur Einschränkung der Pandemie,
des Ansteckungsgeschehen eintritt, ja, äh was in ihrem äh Kompetenzschwerpunkt liegt, die muss sich da den Mund fusselig reden und wird auch noch verarscht.
So sieht das aus.
Ja, das ist so diese Prominenten äh Verführung, ja. Irgendjemand ist prominent und hat X gesagt und dann dann müssen dann alle darüber diskutieren oder nehmen das irgendwie für bare Münze. Ich halt's dann äh an der Stelle dann doch mit Jürgen Klopp.
Weiß nicht, ob du das so mitbekommen hast.
Ist ein Fußballtrainer.
Ist ein Fußballtrainer, ist auch ein ziemlich guter Fußballtrainer, ist auch ein sehr unterhaltsamer Mensch.
Liverpool hatte jetzt so zum zum Englandmeisterschaft geführt, ne?
Champions League gewinnen, also das ist einfach mal der größte äh Erfolg, den man sich überhaupt vorstellen kann
zugegebenermaßen 'ne coole Sau und natürlich haben alle Reporter haben ihn halt gefragt, ja was sind jetzt hier mit Corona und wie ist denn die Situation einzuschätzen.
Bei der Pressekonferenz. Also, Leute, ich bin Fußballtrainer. Was fragt ihr mich so einen Scheiß?
Stört dich, ey.
Kitzelten Experten und fragt die, ich bin Fußballtrainer. Was soll ich denn davon wissen?
Sogar noch gesagt, ich habe ich bin ein Idiot mit einer Mütze oder sowas.
Kommen auf die Formulierung nicht mehr. Er hat ja immer sehr spaßige Formulierungen am Start, aber er lässt irgendwas überhaupt gar keinen Zweifel daran, dass er schon allein deshalb fassungslos ist, dass sie auch nur auf die Idee kommen, ihn zu diesem Scheiß zu befragen
geschweige denn, dass er auch nur bereit ist, da auch nur ein Müh sich so zu äußern.
Ja und nicht weil er jetzt irgendwelchen unangenehmen Fragen aus dem Weg gehen wollte, sondern weil er einfach sagt, da gibt's Leute, die die haben das studiert, die die kennen sich da aus, geht doch, geht doch da hin irgendwie, was verbringt ihr eure Zeit? Es interessiert
keine Sau, was ein Fußballtrainer meint, was vielleicht unter Umständen in dieser Situation das Richtige ist, zu tun. Und dann haben diese gesagt.
Aha, okay, der Fußballtrainer hört uns nicht zu. Energie war doch zum Rapper.
Ja, genau. Rapper bleib bei deiner Dieter. Ehrlich, das ist.
Zum Heulen, ey.
Okay, gut.
So viel zur zur Luca Pflicht in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und ein privates Unternehmen, bei dem die Lizenz von, das ist unglaublich, die die haben jetzt grade verordnet, dass das Landeseinheitlich mehr oder weniger verpflichten,
mit dem System funktionieren soll, für das sie sich jetzt, für das sie für ein Jahr jetzt dann Millionenbetrag zahlen.
Und wenn das Jahr um ist, dann wird das nicht billiger, mein Freund, das wird dann nicht billiger. Oh, unglaublich, unglaublich. Zum Glück ist das nicht mein Geld. Ich zahle ja in in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern keine Steuern.
Ja und während findet Telefon-Hotline, da sehe ich ja das Ding mit den laufenden Kosten, das sehe ich,
Ja, das das ist nachvollziehbar. Man kann sich über einen Preis streiten so, aber da da werden am laufenden Meter Leute ähm damit beschäftigen sich die ganze Zeit,
aber jetzt irgendwie so diese Lizenzkosten dann so in in alle Ewigkeit fortführen, okay, ist nicht klar, ob dann sozusagen in der Zukunft dieselben Beträge aufgerufen werden, aber es ist dann halt darum, wesentlichen Software, die dann existiert und einfach äh zum Einsatz gebracht wird,
Na ja, egal.
Es ist.
Okay, dann äh kommen wir jetzt mal ein bisschen so, was was ist sonst noch in der Netzpolitik äh und in der Welt passiert? Erster finde ich sehr schön, einen Artikel, ein äh Paper ähm von Florian Gallwitz und Michael Kral. Ähm,
Mit dem Titel The Rise and Fall of Social Bot Research. Äh einige erinnern sich ja noch, das war hier mal vor ein paar Jahren das ganz große Thema mit den Social Bots. Wird auch immer mal wieder, wenn das aufkommt, wird meine ähm Stellungnahme damals im,
was war das denn nun mal? Ich glaube im Auftrag des wissenschaftlichen Dienstes des Bundestags hat da irgendwie so eine Anhörung stattgefunden wo der.
Professor Hägel, der da so der sich der zwischenzeitlich sich auf Twitter, ich glaube
Professor Bot oder Mister Bot genannt hat oder sowas, weil er sich für den für den Star des Bod Research gehalten hat. Ähm dieses Video verlinke ich auch nochmal in den da habe ich vor ein paar Jahren meine Meinung äh dazu gesagt, was,
ich, also was ich von dieser ganzen Bot-Forschung halte, ziemlich genau die gleiche Perspektive vertreten, der Florian Galwitz und der Michael Krei. Ähm,
Wenn ich mich nicht täusche, ist der Gallwitz äh Professor in Nürnberg,
aber ähm jedenfalls äh schaut sich damit an und haben dann äh mal die Studien.
Angeschaut, welche was diese die Peer-Review-Studies so haben, ähm,
und sagen am Ende andaute Least mit Twitter
inconspicue äh und sagen damit im Prinzip alle,
Studien, die irgendetwas zu Social Bots gemacht haben, weil sie diese Messmethoden verwendet haben, das sogenannte Bottometer.
Haben äh falsch falsche positive und Artefakte äh ihrer äh ihrer äh fehlerhaften Messmethoden,
gemessen. Und das halte ich für 'ne sehr plausibles Ergebnis ehrlich gesagt.
Florian Galwitz ist äh Professor an der technischen Hochschule Nürnberg und wenn ich das richtig sehe für die Gebiete Medieninformatik und Mustererkennung zuständig, also durchaus ein Feld, was hier in diesen Bereich reinfällt.
So, dann hatten wir darüber gesprochen, dass es äh dass der Bundesrat der Neuregelung des Bestandsdatengesetzes äh nicht zugestimmt hat. Und dann, wenn der Bundesrat nicht zustimmt, dann geht es in den Vermittlungsausschuss und da haben sie sich jetzt
äh ja geeinigt. Jetzt gibt es höhere Hürden.
Für die Herausgabe von Passwörtern, Nutzungs- und Kundendaten und damit wird das dann wohl auch ähm verabschiedet werden. Ähm.
Und das ist äh wie gesagt.
Keine besonders gute Sache, weil ich meine diese Passwortherausgabe das ist eine ziemlich üble ähm.
Ziemlich üble Nummer, denn ähm eigentlich kann ein Anbieter,
das Passwort nicht herausgeben, wenn er es äh äh sinnvoll speichert und sinnvoll sichert.
Nur sinnvoll, sondern auch Gesetzeskonform.
Ja, äh äh genau. Gesetzeskonform speichert.
Dann hatten wir hier auch vor einiger Zeit über diese Schufa-Check Now gesprochen. Ähm.
Wo sie irgendwie so einen Schnell-Check dir anbieten wollten. Ähm.
Und um Menschen mit ähm mangelnder Bonität trotzdem äh irgendwie Zugang zu äh eine zweite Chance zu geben. Also im Prinzip die Leuten.
Die quasi äh die Leute, denen sie den Zugang zu Kredit.
Würdigkeit verlangen, Dienstleistungen verwehren. Denen haben sie gesagt, pass auf, ihr könnt uns ja einfach mal auf euer Konto gucken lassen,
Vielleicht überlegen wir uns das anders. Wir analysieren dann einfach eure Kontoumsätze und vielleicht kommen wir zu dem Ergebnis, dass ihr ja doch äh kreditwürdig seid und hier den Handyvertrag bekommt.
Ja? Ziemlich übel, die Leute, die eben schlechte Schufa-Bonität haben, kommen da immer schwer raus. Und der Grund ist, dass die Schufa ihnen nicht sagt, was sie anders machen müssten, um da rauszukommen und hier wollten sie eben sagen, ja, dann lasst uns mal auf euer Konto gucken,
Vielleicht kriegt er dann eine zweite Chance. Das hat natürlich.
Kritik bekommen und deswegen stellen sie dieses Projekt jetzt auch,
ein. Ja, sie hatten es ursprünglich mit O2 geprüft, äh Testbetrieb und wollen das jetzt nicht weiter verfolgen, dieses.
Und wir hatten über die Bürger Identifikationsnummer gesprochen, wo also die Steuer-ID jetzt zukünftig für die unterschiedlichen ähm,
Datenhaltungen, die der Staat und seine Länder über uns äh anführen,
zum einen zum einen eindeutigen und einzigen werden soll mit dem Register Modellierungsgesetz äh das soll,
jetzt also kommen. Ja, wir wurde am sechsten April verkündet, weil der Bundesrat zugestimmt hat und damit,
Ist das jetzt entschieden und wird passieren. Ähm wir hatten.
Darüber gesprochen, dass äh die Sorge besteht, dass das eben.
Profilbildung über die unterschiedlichen Datenhaltung des Staates und entsprechend mehr Überwachung der Bürger bietet. Wir haben aber auch gewürdigt,
dass es ähm potenziell die Effizienz der Verwaltung und des E-Government äh erhöhen,
könnte. Ähm allerdings hat eine einheitliche Personenkennziffer und der Streit darum in der Bundesrepublik eben eine.
Jahrzehnte lange Tradition und wurde aus guten Gründen bisher abgelehnt. Ähm.
Ich persönlich kann das nicht, ich habe da mich immer ein bisschen zurückgehalten, meine finale Meinung zu zu formulieren. Hm.
Wir haben hier leider eine eine Welt, in der viele andere Stellen äh uns solche IDs einfach geben, ohne,
dass wir die, dass wir uns da überhaupt gegen wehren können. Das heißt aber nicht notwendigerweise, dass es der Staat jetzt auch unbedingt machen soll. Also ich war da immer irgendwie.
Ja, nicht so nicht so hundert Prozent mit meiner Meinung festgelegt,
Wie gesagt, es steht hier gibt's eine eine lange Tradition, die sich dagegen äh gewehrt hat.
Ja die Debatte hatten wir hier glaube ich auch schon mal geführt. Nicht so lange,
Zeit und es ist halt einfach auf der einen Seite haben wir eine eine Gesellschaft und wir sehen das jetzt auch gerade bei der wunderbar bei dieser ganzen Impfkampagne, ja, wo alle am fluchen sind, warum das nicht besser koordiniert werden kann, warum da irgendwie,
da da der Datenzugriff im im Katastrophenfall,
äh nicht ausreichend funktioniert, um irgendwie ein beschleunigtes Impfprogramm oder zumindest ein gut koordiniertes Impfprogramm bundeseinheitlich zu lösen. Äh,
und auf der anderen Seite gab's immer Widerstände gegen gegen solche IDs, die jetzt sicherlich nicht die Antwort auf alle Fragen sind, ja, aber die natürlich schon eine ganze Menge dann eben auch ermöglichen. Das ist, sagen wir mal, auch im.
Klassische Bruchlinie in der auch in diesem CC-Oberthema,
Chancen und Risiken von Technologie abwägen. Ja wie sagt man so schön,
Es ist ein Spannungsfeld. Und wir haben dieses Spannungsfeld haben wir immer bei allem auf die ein oder andere Art und Weise und das hier ist so ein ganz klassisches Beispiel dafür. Das wäre natürlich schon ein Interesse daran haben,
Computern oder Informationstechnik im Allgemeinen uns letzten Endes das Zusammenleben halt auch zu zu optimieren, wo es eben äh angenehme Effekte haben kann. Aber dabei eben auch immer die Risiken im Auge haben,
Oft war diese Diskussion auch von so fundamentalistischen,
Positionen geprägt, teilweise auch gut nachvollziehbar. So, man darf X gar nicht erst einführen, weil ab dann kriegt man's nie wieder in den Griff.
Die Meinung kann man äh vertreten und in manchen Bereichen ist es auch so.
Ne? Auf der anderen Seite kann man dagegen argumentieren und sagen, ja gut, aber dann dann werden wir hier auch nie einen bestimmten Optimierungsschritt gehen können, der eigentlich von allen auch gewünscht wird.
Da. Und und das ist nicht mit mit einer klaren, mit so einem äh Zauberstrich,
auflösbar dieses Problem, sondern es hängt dann halt einfach davon ab, okay, wie wird es umgesetzt? Mit welchen begleitenden äh Regulierungen wird das Ganze in die Welt äh getragen? Schaffen wir,
sichere äh Grenz,
über Grenzübertretungswarnungen, die in irgendeiner Form automatisch und effizient sind, ja? Auf die man sich dann auch verlassen kann. Das, das sind dann sozusagen die Sachen, die man debattieren muss. Und ich denke, uns stehen noch
einige dieser Debatten ähm bevor gerade äh weil der Schub neuer Technologien ähm da so groß ist
Gesichtserkennung hatten wir ja auch schon ein paar Mal, ist so ein Thema. Äh das ganze Machine Learning, diese ganze äh Automatisierung auf Daten wird uns noch eine ganze Menge dieser Fragestellungen,
auf den Tisch legen, wird einfach passieren.
Äh und und genau vor dem Hintergrund, ne, wenn man also wenn du jetzt schon Gesichtserkennung und Machine Learning und so, ne, ich meine, wenn das,
irgendwann eine Bürgeraldie geknotet ist, ne, dann kannst du das technisch nicht mehr von von China unterscheiden, ne. Also das sind ja jetzt äh oder was heißt, sorry, was heißt von China unterscheiden von dem, was man in äh.
In China befürchtet und teilweise auch sieht, was eben der Social Scoring ähm betrifft, wo also das Sozialverhalten erfasst wird. Ja, da gibt's auch eine ganze Menge äh Missinformationen in dem Bereich, aber ja, die ähm,
Man muss sich, man muss sich die Frage stellen und ich habe die grundsätzlich, dass es nicht gut ist,
Wenn eine Institution so viel Macht und Einfluss und Wissen über äh Personen hat und das ist, dass Facebook, das hat, ist etwas schlechtes und es ist nicht erstrebenswert, dass der Staat das auch bekommt, ja? Ähm.
Und erst recht nicht, wenn man sich überlegt, was eben Machine learning, Technologien und so mit so mit solchen Daten machen können,
wenn es viele Jahre später ist. Aber im Zweifelsfall ist ein anderer Weg, den ich eben auch sehen da kann, ja, der bisher ähm,
Der verbreitete zu sein scheint, dass man natürlich trotzdem auch bestimmte Anwendungen auf Daten äh verbieten kann und verschiedene Nutzungen von Daten und äh vielleicht trotzdem eine effizientere Datenhaltung,
im Sinne der Verwaltung ermöglichen kann. Ich glaube, das sind so die beiden. Die beiden Enden der der Diskussion hier
nicht ganz so schön ist mit den einheitlichen ITs, ja. Wir sind ja bei den privaten Anbietern gerade gewesen, ja? Äh Max Schremps hat sich mal wieder jemanden geschnappt äh zum Verklagen, der nimmt sich ja nur.
Sagen wir mal, Multi Multimilliardenkonzerne.
Legt sich nur mit den Großen an.
Genau. Max ist so einer, der kloppt nicht auf die Kleinen. Das kann man ihm nicht vorwerfen, der ähm und zwar,
wirft er Google vor, dass Android-Nutzer ohne deren Zustimmung äh getrackt werden?
Und fordert von der französischen Datenschutzbehörde eine Untersuchung, hat also eine Klage in Frankreich eingereicht, ähm weil Android-Telefone eine ähm ID haben,
Eine eindeutige Werbe-ID, die ist Google und Drittanbietern ermöglicht eben diese das Surfverhalten der Nutzer zu verfolgen und sie gezielt mit Werbung anzusprechen. Ähm.
Und es gab da in letzter Zeit so unterschiedliche Aktionen auch von Google, dass sie gesagt haben, ey yo, wir
wir wir upgraden jetzt, dass der nicht mehr so ohne weitere Strickanbieter Cookies nimmt. Und auf den ersten Blick denkt man, oh krass, ne, die machen diesen Drittanbieter äh Cookiemarkt.
Äh kaputt. Das ist ja eine schöne Sache. Wenn Google dir aber selber nochmal eine ID untergeschoben hat, ja, die ähm,
die quasi in deinem Browser oder in deinem Gerät selber lauert, dann ist natürlich dieser dieser Move,
potentiell anders zu bewerten, weil es damit nämlich eigentlich heißt, dass sie ihre vorherrschende äh Macht im Browser ausnutzen, um zu sagen, alles klar, jetzt wo wir in dem Ding eine Tracking-ID drin haben,
Machen wir mal die anderen Wege des Tracking kaputt, weil sind ja die von der Konkurrenz. Also das ist auch irgendwie alles sehr äh sehr unschön. Ähm.
Es ist nicht so, als würde ähm
Apple das nicht auch machen. Es gibt die IDFA, ähm der dagegen hat ähm also die NGO von Max auch zusammen mit einem mit einer Privatperson geklagt. Das wird vor,
Von österreichischen und spanischen Datenschützern geprüft, ähm muss man mal schauen,
wie äh sich diese Dinge bewegen.
Ähm sind, denke ich, sehr wichtige und fundamentale Fragen, die da mal geklärt werden müssen und ähm ist gut, dass das macht.
So, ganz viele IDs, die wir heute zusammengetragen haben, QR-Codes, Burger-ITs.
Genau, damit sind wir aber immerhin am Ende der Sendung.
Ja, das ist der einzige Vorteil.
Auch äh noch besser auf. Wir haben sehr viel äh positives Feedback für unseren unser Auto gefunden in der letzten Sendung.
Schönen Gruß an Danger Dan,
und dann haben wir noch einen Job, der äh ausgeschrieben ist, der bittet uns Thomas Lohninger, euch darauf aufmerksam zu machen.
Der äh hat ja äh die NGO Epicenter works in Wien,
die im äh ja, Datenschutz und digitale Rechtebereich aktiv ist. Thomas kennt ja hier regelmäßig als äh Teammitglied. Ähm und äh Sendungsmitgestalter ähm.
Auf Etribene ebenfalls sehr aktiv und Epicenter schreibt aus, äh die Stelle einer Communication Manager.
Männlich, weiblich, divers. Ähm ist im Internet zu Hause und deshalb gibt's bei uns auch immer viel zu tun.
Wir stehen für eine Politik, die Grund- und Freiheitsrechte im digitalen Zeitalter konsequent und ohne Einschränkungen durchsetzt und dabei unabhängig von allen politischen Parteien und Firmen ist. Das Internet hat enormes Potential für eine offene Demokratie, eine gerechte Gesellschaft und faire Wirtschaft. Dafür stehen wir.
Genau, also wenn ihr da als Communication Manager äh.
Netzpolitische Themen in Mailings, Blogposts, Presseaussendung, Interviews und Pressekonferenzen ähm vorausbringen möchtet, dann könnte das ein,
Job sein in Wien zehn neunzig teilweise Remote und sind möglich,
Regelbetrieb während Corona im Home Office und potenziell auch eine Umzugsprämie, wenn dein Hauptwohnsitz weit außerhalb von Wien liegt.
Und die Stelle ist frei zum ersten Juni zwanzig einundzwanzig. Vollzeit. Ja, wenn euch das interessiert, findet ihr den Link in den,
Shoutouts. Ja. Damit werden wir jetzt haben wir unser Soll erfüllt Tim.
Für heute.
Können wir wieder, können wir wieder Luca-Check-Ins machen,
War nett, war nett.
Ja, im Zoo war's auch super. Machen wir uns nix vor, also die Geschichte mit der Corona-Warn-App, das war so.
Hm so eine Ausnahme,
Ne, also es ist noch nicht so, dass das das das jetzt schon wirklich zu irgendeinem nennenswerten Umdenken geführt hätte oder dass irgendjemand auch nur begriffen hätte, dass sie da ausnahmsweise mal was richtig gemacht haben
Das wird noch eine Weile äh dauern und braucht wahrscheinlich auch nochmal einen Generationswechsel in der Politik,
Also langsam müssten ja mal so die die Digitalchecker müssen ja dann irgendwann auch langsam mal groß sein,
Ich weiß nicht, ob's am Ende wirklich das bringt, aber es ähm nervt einfach, langsam richtig. Mich nervt's.
Also unabhängig von allem, ja. Es ist.
Also ich man muss da einfach mal dann den Bundesrechnungshof hinschicken und fragen, ob das wirklich wenn du schon Millionen
für Millionen eine App hast, die Millionen Leute haben und dann kommen irgendwelche windigen Leute und schaffen es mit einer dreimonatigen PR-Werbe-Talkshow-Kampagne dich dazu zu bringen, den Millionen in den Rachen zu werfen,
du sogar, wie jetzt hier ähm äh Oberregierender, Unterbürgermeister von Berlin mit Müller, dann auch noch sagst, ich habe mir das gar nicht angeguckt. Ich habe den einfach gekauft.
Wo du noch nimmer, ich habe auch gar keine Ahnung, aber das äh klang gut. Ähm dann muss man sich fragen,
ob das vielleicht ähm.
Gar nicht so gut war und bin vielleicht gar, ob da vielleicht Geld verschwendet wurde. Die Frage wird man wird man ja wohl noch stellen dürfen. Und das während wirklicher, ne, das haben wir in der letzten Sendung betont, müssen es hier heute nochmal machen.
Während eine überlegene, nämlich dezentrale und in sonstigen Bereichen ähm.
Mindestens ebenbürtige alternative in die Corona-Warn-App eingebaut wird mit Mitteln des Bundes, ja.
Und während andere ähm ähnlich schlechte Konzepte wie Luca äh leer ausgehen, ja das muss ja auch erstmal rechtfertigen und dann,
Ganz ehrlich, also hier im Fall von Baden-Württemberg, Eva hatte das ja in der letzten Sendung schon gesagt, drei Komma sieben Millionen ohne Ausschreibung,
für einen QR-Codescanner. Boah ey, da musst du aber äh da musst du erklären. Da kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, hm.
Dass da nicht mal äh jemand eine Frage stellt. Da kann ich mir vorstellen.
Dass die Anke Domscheidberg äh oder andere ähm da schon mal die die richtigen Fragen stellen. Da kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das so in Ordnung ist.
Das ist unter Garantie nicht und da wird sich also die Diskussion ist auch glaube ich noch nicht äh vorbei.
Ja, aber weiße Tim, äh die eine Sache ist ja, weil wir wissen ja, der Datenschutz steht der Pandemiebekämpfung im Weg, ne,
und diese ganzen Regeln gegen Korruption, die auch, das haben wir ja gesehen, da holst du mal ein paar Masken, rucki, zucki, bis sie hier der Korruption äh beschuldigt, nur weil er,
ja einen mittleren, einen mittleren sechsstelligen Betrag an Provision kassiert hast. So, da ist ja ruck zuck äh in Asien hingegen, Tim, ne, da wäre das alles ähm.
Viel einfacher gewesen.
Ja, ich meine, warst du denn nicht korruptionsbekämpfung, funktioniert nur auf Inseln?
Ja ja.
Sophie, Keime an Inseln und Isle of Man und.
Der der Asiate hat da einfach eine ganz andere Mentalität, Tim.
Oh Mann, ey.
So ist es. So ist es. Na ja, Leute, lasst euch nicht rumkriegen. Wir wir sind dafür die coolsten. Wir alle. Hä? Wir haben zumindest gecheckt. Ist auch was.
Ihr kriegt jetzt alle einen Orden von uns grade verliehen. Ihr seid alle die coolsten.
Könnt ihr euch schon mal freuen, äh sagen wir mal, die halbwegs aufgeklärte Tech Bubble, die jetzt äh ein Jahr lang.
In den in den seltenen äh sozialen Treffen und Zoom-Konferenzen sich anhören musste, die Verschwörungstheorien über die Corona-Warn-App,
jetzt wird der Tisch umgedreht. Jetzt könnt ihr euch demnächst äh was? Du gibst nicht deine Daten ein in die App von den Smudo, dass wir hier äh sitzen können, in ein Restaurant drinne,
Was ist denn mit dir los? Das ist so ein für drei das äh da da da freue ich mich auch, wenn wenn sich hier wenn sich hier jetzt das Blatt wendet.
Die Aufklärung, die muss noch vorangehen. Aber ihr seid ja alle erleuchtet, ne. Okay, dann wünschen wir euch noch eine schöne Woche, sagen tschüss. Bis bald.
Ciao ciao.